antenne de 20h le journal de la
rédaction
henri sannier bonsoir et merci d'être
fidèle au journal d'antenne 2 à la une
ce soir les actions du groupe suez dans
la tourmente des marchés boursiers 261
francs pour la première cotation alors
que son prix d'offre était de 317 francs
bilan fait les comptes -17%
un chiffre qui renforcent l'incertitude
qui pèse sur la suite des privatisations
traitement des fonctionnaires plus 2,1
pour cent cette année au lieu des 1,7
prévu un coup de pouce qui n'a rien
électorale assure le ministre de la
fonction publique
arrivé à paris du président chinois
ligue signal pour une visite officielle
de quatre jours c'est la première fois
qu'un chef d'état chinois seront en
europe m l'europe spatiale sur orbite le
club des 13 pays membres est réunie à la
hâte un accord dépend d'un rapprochement
de vues entre français et allemands
avantage antenne 2 qui retransmettra le
tournoi de roland garros en association
avec fr3 le couplage des deux chaînes
publiques permettra de diffuser en
direct et intégralement les principaux
matchs une journée supplémentaire de
détention pour marcel carton
marcel fontaine jean paul kauffmann jean
louis normandin d'antenne 2 et roger
auque les otages français au liban n'ont
toujours pas été libérés
la bonne nouvelle pour huit millions de
fonctionnaires hervé de charette le
ministre de la fonction publique a
annoncé ce midi sur antenne 2 un
rattrapage salarial d'un pour cent à
compter du 1er mai 87 1% qui remplace
les 0 6% qui devait intervenir le 1er
novembre
apparemment le ministre a surpris tout
le monde je ne fais pas d'électoralisme
at il dit mais je pense que les efforts
consentis par l'immense majorité des
fonctionnaires justifie cette petite
contrepartie un discours nouveau qui
mérite vous en souviendrez quelques
explications concrètes
véronique auger l'air brut de vimy
francs par mois c'est le salaire moyen
de la fonction publique en novembre
le fonctionnaire recevra en plus 1% au
lieu des 0 6% prévus au départ 1% de
8000 francs égale 80 francs
le traitement de novembre sera de 8000
80 francs en décembre il recevra 8080
francs plus un rattrapage l'équivalent
de 1 % sur tous ces salaires depuis mai
soit six fois 80 francs 480 francs le
traitement de décembre sera de 8500 60
francs en janvier il sera de nouveau à
8000 80 francs ces augmentations sont
supérieures à celles proposées par le
gouvernement aux syndicats au début de
l'année + 2,1 pour cent au lieu de
1 27% et si l'on tient compte des
promotions et de l'ancienneté
les traitements auront augmenté de 3 5%
au lieu de trois pour cent un cadeau qui
n'a rien d'électoral d'après le ministre
de la fonction publique comme parent est
la contrepartie justifier de l'effort
qui a été demandée à l'ensemble de
l'administration pendant ces deux années
vous savez qu'on a fait des réductions
d'effectifs vous savez que nous avons eu
une politique dont je ne méconnais pas
qu'elle impliquait une certaine sagesse
à raison de l'année du redressement
économique
eh bien je crois que quand on a fait un
effort il faut qu'à un moment on s'y
retrouve lui en ce qui nous concerne
nous avions bien fait sentir au mini ce
que ce serait de la provocation de panne
ou de la même chose qu'aux secteurs
nationalisés qui avait signé un accord
salarial
je crois que c'est clair c'est que la
mobilisation des fonctionnaires le 15
octobre à à payer elle a payé alors que
le gouvernement cherchait à les
minimiser
aujourd'hui il est contraint d'en tenir
compte c'est donc le sens de cette
mesure supplémentaire qui a été accordée
aujourd'hui dans l'ensemble c'est plutôt
une bonne nouvelle pour les
fonctionnaires même si certains ceux qui
ne bénéficient pas de promotion cette
année vont perdre du pouvoir d'achat
ils recevront 2,1 pour cent alors que
l'inflation sera de 3,3 pour cent cette
année
il reste que le gouvernement a versé
plus qu il donne un coup de canif à sa
politique d'austérité et à son objectif
de désindexation des salaires sur les
prix
ce changement risque de faire des
envieux dans le secteur privé
à quinze jours du début des négociations
salariales la bourse lundi difficile à
paris avec une baisse de l'ordre de 3,6
pour cent bref les boursiers broie une
nouvelle fois du noir au lendemain d'un
week-end au cours duquel rien n'a été
véritablement réglé côté mener nouveau
recul du dollar mais le franc très
attaquées vendredi s'est bien repris en
face de l'ensemble des devises
c'est dans ce climat plutôt incertain
qui est intervenu aujourd'hui la
première cotation de suez suez qui
encaisse de plein fouet la crise
boursière bilan une première cotation
quasi catastrophe philippe sassier où il
faut dire que beaucoup d'étrangers en
vendus et puis que on a laissé jouer les
lois du marché on n'a pas soutenu le
suez le recul de ce usa la première
cotation est en tout cas spectaculaires
pour deux raisons d'abord elle est
importante près de 20% de repli par
rapport au prix payé par les épargnants
ensuite c'est la première fois qu'une
privatiser
boit la tasse sitôt jeter à l'eau certes
depuis que suez a été mise en vente il y
à un mois
la bourse avait beaucoup baissé mais sa
création d'aujourd'hui montre à
l'évidence que le marché refusent pour
le moment du moins d'avaler de nouvelles
privatisations
aussi séduisante soit elle les anglais
les allemands font la même constatation
cela signifie qu'aucune décision ne peut
être prise
actuellement ce qui concerne la
privatisation de l'uap et aujourd'hui on
enregistre de nouveau et fort recul près
de 4% à londres et à paris plus de 8% à
francfort en suisse et on note environ 8
à 10% de repli wall street baisse
actuellement également tandis que le
dollar est en chute 5,63 francs
actuellement les marchés
pourquoi cette tension bien le marché
s'impatiente de voir que les
gouvernements occidentaux n'arrivent pas
à s'entendre pour se rencontrer en fait
tout tient aux discussions qui se
tiennent actuellement à washington entre
le congrès et la maison blanche pour
trouver un accord sur le fameux déficit
budgétaire tant que cet accord ne sera
pas trouvée
eh bien il n'y aura pas de rencontre et
les marchés vont devenir très nerveux
merci philippe au palais bourbon
violentes attaques du front national
contre la presse le député roger
holeindre a dénoncé je cite le
terrorisme intellectuel pratiqués par la
presse tout en mettant en cause
nommément rachid arhab notre confrère de
la rédaction d'antenne 2 commentant les
reportages de rachid arhab consacrée à
la nouvelle calédonie roger holeindre a
notamment déclaré il est de nationalité
algérienne
il n'a pas le droit de donner ses
impressions sur la politique intérieure
française
autre petite phrase assassine je cite
certains porteurs de micros ont parfois
plus de mal que certains voyous porteurs
de pistolets le terrorisme en col blanc
des journalistes est le plus dangereux
il est beaucoup plus dangereux que tous
les autres terrorisme je vous laisse
seul juge
mais il est évident ce soir que nous ne
pouvons laisser passer je le dis avec
beaucoup de gravité ce genre de propos
et les vanniers en effet en france tout
le monde
simple citoyen ou parlementaire a le
droit de critiquer la presse les
journalistes ne sont pas infaillibles
on peut nous reprocher en effet telle
erreur d'analysé telle imprécision
mais ce n'est pas ce que fait
aujourd'hui monsieur l'art monsieur la
dhr s'estime victime d'un complot vous
l'avez entendu
nous serions plus dangereux que des
terroristes armés allons monsieur
l'indre tout ce qui est excessif est
dérisoire et comme il manque d'arguments
précis le député du front national a
recours à une bonne vieille recette les
xénophobie il s'en prend à un reporter
d'antenne 2 rachid arhab dont le seul
crime est d'être à ses yeux de
nationalité algérienne à ce titre rachid
arhab n'aurait pas droit
selon monsieur l'indre n'aurait pas le
droit de parler de politique française
absurde d'abord rachid arhab est un
journaliste comme les autres à antenne 2
et ensuite c'est un mois directeur de
l'information et non à monsieur l'indre
de décider des sujets traités par rachid
arhab et rassurez vous si les traitait
mal il ne serait plus à l'antenne mais
ce n'est pas le cas que les choses
soient claires nous continuerons à faire
notre métier dans la plus parfaite
sérénité et j'aimerais citer monsieur
l'indre une phrase une phrase d'un bon
français monsieur voltaire qui écrivait
amis racines les injures atroce n'ont
jamais fait de tort qu'à ceux qui les
ont dit les journalistes du service
politique d'antenne 2 indique
unanimement qu'ils n'ont pour l'auteur
des propos tenus à l'assemblée nationale
que le plus profond mépris je cite leur
propos ils refuseront désormais
systématiquement d'interviewer un député
qui s'illustre par des attaques aussi
basse humainement qu'injustifiée
professionnellement parlant
autre communiqué de la société des
rédacteurs d'antenne de communiqué qui
vient de me parvenir la société des
journalistes d'antenne 2 s'élève avec
indignation contre les propos
discriminatoires tenus cet après midi
devant l'assemblée nationale devant la
représentation nationale par monsieur
roger holeindre député du front national
la société des journalistes ne peut
accepter qu'un élu du peuple tente de
salir l'honnêteté la compétence et les
qualités professionnelles de notre
confrère rachid arhab
toute la rédaction d'antenne 2 s'estime
insultée par ce député
ce genre d'intimidation ne l'empêchera
pas de poursuivre sa mission
d'information
fin de citation et voilà tout ce que
nous voulions dire unanimement ce soir
pour l'ensemble de la rédaction antenne
de l'x yamgnane à paris un événement car
c'est la première fois qu'un président
chinois séjournent en france monsieur
kofi yamgnane été accueillis cet après
midi à paris par le président françois
mitterrand visite symbolique qui
témoigne de
intérêt grandissant de la chine pour
notre pays il faut dire que la france
est le premier grand pays occidental à
avoir reconnu la chine c'était en 1964
visite importante car elle survient au
lendemain du congrès du pc chinois
un congrès qui confirme les orientations
réformistes du régime en chine
le message du 13e congrès passe
incontestablement et il fait bouger les
mentalités
même dans les régions les plus éloignées
de la capitale
le reportage que vous allez voir a été
tourné à 2000 km de pékin
dans l'un des villages qui a servi de
base révolutionnaire un mode c'est tout
reportage de christian quérou échos du
dos
dans ce petit village de 130 habitants
les paysans suivi avec intérêt des
résultats du 13e congrès du parti
communiste chinois
ils ont appris parfois à leurs dépens
que leur vie était tributaire du pouvoir
central
pour l'heure la confiance règne je pense
que le 13e congrès va nous apporter de
bons changements au niveau de vie des
paysans va encore augmenter
le node dans les monts du qinghai et
comme dans tout le pays et de le dire at
a même eu qu'à suivre
les communes populaires sont mortes et
enterrées aujourd'hui chacun est
responsable de l'espace qu'il cultive
sans parler des fameux lopin de terre
qui permettent d'arrondir les fins de
mois à daqing comme partout en chine
les paysans sont les grands gagnants des
réformes
là où tu joues et sa femme en train de
fabriquer des ballets de bambou sont
persuadés eux que le mouvement est
irréversible au niveau de vie des
paysans a augmenté sensiblement ces
derniers temps grâce à la politique du
parti et de l'état
ma vie aussi s'est améliorée une
paysanne comme moi et plus heureuse car
c'est moins fatigant et on gagne plus
quel est votre prochain achat
monsieur ou monsieur zhu et l'année
prochaine je vais acheter un poste de
télévision en noir et blanc les joues
semble vraiment heureuse même si leur
seul confort et l'électricité
ils gagnent autant que bien des
fonctionnaires et aspire surtout à vivre
en paix une paix qu'on célèbre en chine
avec des pétards en irlande l'ira
l'armée républicaine irlandaise au banc
des accusés l'attentât d'enniskillen
attentat qui a fait je vous le rappelle
onze morts et 60 m haies vient d'être
revendiquée précisément par l'ira
curieuses revendications car
l'organisation revendique l'attentât
tout en le regrettant la bombe a explosé
sans être déclenchée par notre signal
affirme le communiqué de l'armée
républicaine irlandaise depuis 1972
l'ira multiplient les attentats et
entretient un terrorisme sournois
alimentée par la haine qui existe depuis
longtemps entre les communautés
catholique et protestante
philippe harrouard et nice killen des
scènes comme celle ci on en a vu
beaucoup trop en 18 ans de violence en
irlande du nord a accusé les groupes
paramilitaires dont l'ira l'armée
républicaine irlandaise qui luttent pour
la réunification de l'irlande sous le
contrôle des catholiques majoritaires en
république d'irlande dans la province
britannique du nord on trouve surtout
des protestants qui eux veulent par tous
les moyens resté attaché à londres d'où
un conflit inextricable ira dispose
d'une organisation armée qui combat sans
relâche les troupes britanniques
assurant la sécurité en irlande du nord
l'ira a aussi une branche politique de
chine feng opposé à toute violence
contre les civils
car cela décrédibilise l'organisation
seulement voilà dira c'est également une
armée qui flirte avec le terrorisme et
le banditisme et cela crée des
dissensions entre groupes modérés et
extrémistes exemple lors de l'attentât
contre le magasin harrods à londres
à noël 83 lira revendique le chine feng
présente ses excuses
l'ira est aujourd'hui en difficulté
manque d'argent d'armes surtout après la
saisie de la cargaison en france
plusieurs de ses dirigeants ont été
arrêtés ou tués ces derniers mois c'est
partiellement le résultat de l'accord de
coopération antiterroriste entre londres
et dublin signé il y a juste deux ans et
qui fonctionne plutôt bien
les problèmes de l'ira peuvent expliquer
l'attentât odieux d'enniskillen le tout
pour le tout mais est ce un acte isolé
des extrémistes ou un changement de
tactique de l'organisation ira questions
pour l'instant sans réponse en tunisie
transition dans le calme après la
destitution d'un dip bourguiba dès hier
le nouveau chef de l'état monsieur ben
ali a fait part de sa volonté de
démocratiser le régime le peuple at il
dit est digne d'une vie politique
évoluée
aujourd'hui la vie a repris son cours
tout à fait normalement pas de
renforcement de mesures de sécurité dans
les rues l'ex président bourguiba a été
transféré dans une résidence à 40 km de
la capitale
quant à l'opposition tunisienne elle
réagit plutôt bien aux changements sur
place notre envoyé spécial jacques
merlino deux jours après son accession
au pouvoir le président ben ali a la
situation bien en main la population est
toujours aussi calme et aucune critique
n'est formulée ni du côté des partis de
l'opposition ni du côté des syndicats
mieux encore le président ben ali
bénéficie du soutien mesuré les plus
grands partis d'opposition le mouvement
démocratique socialiste
son leader achmed mestiri veut parier
sur les nouvelles chances de la
démocratie ou consensus doit se traduire
dans les modalités et les formes de la
représentation populaire
en clair ça signifie des élections alors
quand et comment ça c'est une question à
discuter le bouton ben ali est un ancien
général ça ne vous inquiète pas non non
vous savez
il a il a pris toutes les précautions à
toutes les formes la pluie toutes les
initiatives pour montrer que ce n'est
pas un militaire qui a pris le pouvoir
il a eu le mérite de faire le geste
qu'il faut pour sortir la tunisie de
l'impasse dans laquelle il a fait sauter
un verrou qui bloquaient toutes les
portes vers les vous une évolution
pacifique de la crise il a fait c'est
quand même un mérite que nous n'avons
pas été les seuls à souligner j'ai
appris ce matin
les islamistes ont sorti un ex où ils
disent que eux aussi encore quelque
sorte le préjugé favorable sous ben ali
quant à l'ex président bourguiba il est
maintenant installé à mornag dans une
résidence discrète à l'abri des regards
et des caméras à amman au lendemain de
la poignée de mains très remarquée entre
le président syrien hafez el-assad et le
chef de l'olp et yasser arafat le sommet
du monde arabe s'est déroulée à huis
clos aujourd'hui au coeur du débat
les relations syro irakienne et la
guerre du golfe à amman notre envoyé
spécial jean marc il use a rencontré
madame kaufmann les pousses de notre
confrère jean-paul kauffmann joëlle
kauffmann qui est l'invité du secrétaire
de la ligue arabe entend profiter du
sommet pour dialoguer avec les autorités
islamiques
je suis venu ici à l'invitation du
président qui bique et le président de
la ligue pour rencontrer grâce à lui
avoir des contacts avec les différentes
délégations des pays du monde arabe qui
sont représentés ici
est ce que vous seriez prête aussi à
vous rendre à téhéran
je suis prête à me rends à teyran s'ils
ont bien vite comme je participe à
toutes sortes de rencontres aussi
islamique
et actuellement est-ce que vous avez au
fond du nouveau on n'a pas de nouveaux
vraiment parce que les choses sont très
secrète comme il le faut je pense mais
j'ai rencontré ici beaucoup de gens qui
sont assez optimiste et je pense que
j'espère que très bientôt être une
solution polymères et nos amis qu'ils
sont innocents et qu'ils doivent donc
être libérée dans la sphère des otages
du nouveau aujourd'hui le quai d'orsay a
affirmé que l'otage sud-coréen récemment
libéré par ses ravisseurs à beyrouth
avait bien était détenu avec le
journaliste français roger auque autour
du problème des otages je vous rappelle
qu'un comité de journalistes pour la
libération des otages au liban s'est
créé récemment le porte parole du comité
n'est autre que bernard pivot d'antenne
de toujours le mystère autour du
possible enlèvement de 8 personnes par
le groupe palestinien abou nidal
les otages seraient qu'israélien belges
et français je vous rappelle brièvement
les faits on apprenait hier soir qu'un
bateau de plaisance avait été arraisonné
au large de la bande de gaza au large
d'israël par un commando du fatah
conseil révolutionnaire
aujourd'hui rien ne vient confirmer
cette information mais le groupe abou
nidal fait savoir qu'il poursuit les
interrogatoires à tel aviv
les experts israéliens sont visiblement
sceptique voire même étonné une
correspondance de charles enderlin
les israéliens sont persuadés que le
détournement n'a pas eu lieu dans leurs
eaux territoriales ou dans les eaux
internationales voisine patrouiller en
permanence par l'aviation et la marine
israélienne la vigilance était
d'ailleurs renforcé ces derniers jours
par crainte d'une attaque terroriste
pendant le sommet dahmane pour l'heure à
jérusalem on ne sait toujours rien des
circonstances de ce drame et puis en
l'absence de certitudes
le doute subsiste sur la présence
d'israéliens à bord du silver forcément
vers et en très étroite collaboration
avec du gouvernement aux amis dont la
france la belgique d'autres pays qui eux
aussi sont dans le même stade que nous
ait fait d'avoir le plus d'informations
possibles pour l'instant nous en forme
tous au même point dans ces conditions
les responsables israéliens veillent à
ne pas trop pousser le ton des otages
innocents risquent peut-être leur vie la
clé du mystère c'est peut-être en france
tout simplement qu'il faut la chercher
fernandes le propriétaire du voilier
était bien connu dans la région de
toulon jusqu'à ce jour de juin 85 où il
a quitté son emploi pour une destination
inconnue il quitte son emploi en
compagnie de jacqueline valente
jacqueline valentin c'est le nom de la
jeune femme qui figure sur la liste des
otages diffusé par le groupe abou nidal
enquête d'henri bodiguel au rez de
chaussée de cet immeuble de sanary
habite monsieur et madame août keynes eu
des gens âgés d'origine belge leur fils
fernand et emmanuel deux autres adultes
et quatre enfants seraient actuellement
prisonniers à beyrouth mais on n'en
saura pas davantage
adamou de keynes eux c'est la seule que
nous apercevrons pour le fusera de
parler se contentant de répondre quand
on l'interrogeait voyez avec les
affaires étrangères à bruxelles
les gens du quartier les voisins ne
dirons rien ils connaissent la famille
c'est tout quant aux policiers venus
semble-t-il pour éloigner les importuns
ils ont reçu des consignes de silence en
fin d'après midi cependant on apprend
que le père des deux fillettes de 5 et 6
ans dont l'identité n'a pas été révélée
leur père serait à la scène
cette fois la piste est sérieuse car les
informations concordent
l'ex-mari de balle un jeu métive perdent
deux peut-être des petits enfants dont
l'identité n'a pas tiré et des
petits-enfants dont on a dit qu'il
parlait d'elle-même en face c'est fatah
tant qu'il affirme
c'est pour nous parce que vous en parlez
voix et voir comment comment se fait-il
que vos enfants puissent être à bord de
ce bateau en compagnie de monsieur août
15 je suis quelqu'un c'est le concubin
de mon ex femme sont partis depuis 85 à
lui une nouvelle casse et aux nombreuses
plaintes déposées sur tenu dans la ville
on a cherché avec un mandat d'arrêt
contre une source insee madame dhalla et
comment avez vous découvert finalement
qu'ils étaient aux yeux du côté de
beyrouth probablement otage dans la
presse on va tâcher jour dans quelques
instants l'europe de l'espace avec
patrick baudry qui est ce soir notre
invité avance la priorité aux images
choisies les autres faits marquants de
l'actualité
commenté par pascal vanier 40 jours de
conflit des millions de perte la plus
longue grève du premier port français
est terminée à marseille dockers et a
cogné les tenants de la manutention ont
signé une nouvelle convention collective
parmi les accords le port de marseille
baisse ses tarifs pour s'aligner sur ses
concurrents européens
dossier michel droit cncl les parties
civiles saisisse la cour européenne des
droits de l'homme elle estime arbitraire
la décision de la cour de cassation puis
ce vendredi suspension de l'instruction
jusqu'au 10 décembre la cour elle se
réunit demain matin vont apprécier les
remous provoqués par cette affaire le
parti socialiste place la campagne
électorale sur le terrain de l'éducation
laurent fabius défini deux priorités
88-89 un plan d'urgence de 5 milliards
de francs
suivra une loi de programmation sur dix
ans réforme d'ensemble et recrutement de
400 mille enseignants à l'horizon 2000
l'europe l'essentiel des entretiens de
felipe gonzalez avec françois mitterrand
puis jacques chirac cours de sa visite
éclair le chef du gouvernement espagnol
a reçu le soutien de la france pour
l'entrée de son pays dans l'ue au union
européenne de défense il faut réveiller
la conscience européenne a déclaré
felipe gonzalez un mois avant
l'importante réunion des 12 à copenhague
allez hop et ivar l'europe spatiale en
quête d'un second souffle
le pendant 48 heures ministres et
spécialistes planchent sur les
programmes spatiaux de l'an 2000
l'enjeu est important car politiquement
il s'agit de faire preuve d'indépendance
vis-à-vis de l'urss et des usa les deux
grands économiquement parlant l'europe
de l'espace est aussi un défi à l'heure
de la rigueur budgétaire
nos ambitions à l'horizon 2000 passe par
trois projets ariane 5
hermès et columbus le point avec jacques
violet pour que les européens
travaillent à un jour dans l'espace à
côté des américains et des soviétiques
il faut une fusée une navette est une
station orbitale
c'est le financement de ces trois
projets environ 80 milliards de francs
mais aussi un calendrier pour les
construire que l'on discute
la france veut tout et tout de suite
pour ariane-5 une énorme fusée capable
de mettre la navette hermès dans
l'espace pas de problème tout le monde
semble d'accord premier vol prévu pour
1995 les divergences apparaissent
surtout entre français et allemands à
propos des romains c'est de la station
columbus le laboratoire le
vernement allemand souhaiterait
prolonger les études sur hermès de trois
ans et ensuite faire un bilan
technologique pour la station spatiale
bonne voudrait là aussi attendre
notamment que les négociations en cours
avec les états unis sur l'utilisation
pacifique de la station spatiale
américaine est abouti si l'espace fait
souvent rêver les experts par le gros
sous et politiques des problèmes bien
terre à terre alors premières questions
très directes crois qu'il faut faire
comme ça dans une europe en crise est ce
qu'il est raisonnable de mettre 80
milliards de francs sur des projets oui
bien sûr je dirais même au contraire
c'est un excellent investissement est
d'autant plus qu'on est très bien passé
dans le domaine spatial et c'est parce
qu'on est en crise qu'il faut faire les
bons choix
alors cette valse-hésitation autour des
anglais c'est ce qu'elle ne vous
inquiète pas un petit peu non pas du
tout vous savez les équipes travaillent
que ce soit en france ou en europe et le
programme avance la définition est est
maintenant presque figée et on est
absolument serein alors patrick baudry
je vais vous faire bondir il y en a qui
disent quel hermès a déjà un temps de
retard avant même d'être avant même
d'être conçu au point d'être construits
ils veulent sans nous dire que hermès à
20 en avance hermès représente sur le
plan éthique de teknologik un challenge
extrêmement ambitieux pour l'europe et
elle se place sur le plan technologique
toujours bien en delà de ce que ça faire
par exemple les américains avec le
shuttle même parlons pas des américains
parlant des anglais y parle d'avion
hypersonique ils ont peut-être un petit
peu d'avancé sinon oui l'avion
hypersonique c'est la génération
suivante c'est ce à quoi pensent tout le
monde et c'est justement pour cela qu'il
faut réussir armée s'avançant hermès il
n'y aura pas d'avion et personne à l'un
ne va pas sans l'autre
l'un ne va pas sans l'autre il ya des
technologies qu'il faut acquérir il ya
des expériences qu'il faut avoir
il ya un domaine de vol qu'il faut
connaître et tout cela sert mais ce qui
nous permettra de l'acquérir
le premier pilote d'hermès en 97-98 tss
sera patrick baudry qui est sur le pont
on espère et on croise les doigts et il
y aura trois européens et trois vols par
an c'est ça il y aura trois européens et
deux ou trois vols par an
merci mon courage ya du pain sur la
planche effectivement mais ça travaille
bien
bravo merci on sera fixé demain soir je
crois pour le résumer aux maux dont les
allemands vont se trame à peut-être un
tout petit peu de retard par rapport à
ce qui était prévu mais guère
et on attendra nos objectifs alors je
mords a valeur de 800 transit si on va
parler de sport le tennis on y reviendra
demain et on a gagné roland garros gens
ma mère c'est pas mal on a battu c'était
tf1 en cinq sets j'ai lu ça dans le
journal mais on y reviendra
car ce soir il faut parler de football
on a la composition de l'équipe de
france avant le match face à la r d à il
ya des petits nouveaux qui font leur
apparition voilà après la déception
enregistrée contre la norvège il y a
quelques semaines
henri michel a fait là qu'on a fait
confiance à la plupart du groupe nous
allons voir sur ce panneau il y a tout
de même quelques nouveaux notamment
sylvain kastendeuch qui a tout joueur de
metz 24 ans au poste de libéro bruno
germain 27 ans du matra racing au milieu
du terrain et le retour de bruno bellone
à noter la disparition de stopyra et
d'un diani de toute façon les joueurs
français contre la rda le 18 novembre
honte à faire oublier un mauvais match
contre la norvège mais le revers à 20
heures au parc des princes dur dur mais
le résultat importe peu importe peu mais
ça sera très bon pour leur part la
prochaine coupe du monde
la météo ou une météo synonyme de nuages
malheureusement joseph et henry sera
difficile demain échapper au nuage
effectivement ils font un retour en
force toutefois ils donneront un peu
moins de pluie qu'aujourd'hui les voici
ces nuages ils arrivent de toutes parts
du nord ou est ce une nouvelle vague
contenant du nord-ouest une autre en
provenance du sud-ouest alors résultats
demain à la mi-journée à peu près ils se
retrouveront sur lève sur l'alsace le
nord des alpes et midi et la corse dont
toute la journée sur toute cette région
nuages et puis partout ailleurs le ciel
restera couvert avec des ondées surprise
et un espoir de voir quelques rayons du
soleil retour des éclaircies sur la
bretagne la normandie et l'embouchure de
la loire
côté températures c'est le statu quo
c'est-à-dire une relative douceur 8° à
reims et à nancy 11 degrés à vous sur la
moitié sud
10° à limoges 17 à nice et 18 en corse
demain mardi 10 novembre pensées
allaient aux prochains rendez vous
d'information 23h20 exactement avec au
brier de l'air demain dès 6h45 ouvrez
l'oeil comme tous les matins avec télé
matin animée par le trio de choc
catherine ceylac roger zabel emma
recrutement quant à moi je retrouve avec
beaucoup de plaisir demain 20h
excellente soirée sur antenne 2